oh can you pause it there she put her
purse next to the guy so she's coming
closer towards his proximity putting an
object near somebody would not be
happening on the first day trust signal
too because it's her wallet
these three body language experts
we'll watch these five couples going on
dates
can they guess accurately how long these
couples have been dating based only on
their body language
let's begin
what is intriguing to me is on footage
one the bag is on her chair
and she's very close there's a lot of
close Behavior and the guys well doesn't
look very comfortable so I would have to
actually disagree with you that we're
seeing discomfort number one she's
Crossing her arms and making herself
small yes but she's also mirroring her
partner who's doing the same they're
coming together I think that they're
actually really comfortable in each
other's space
foreign
I see a lot of reserved Behavior there
in number one she is covering her
ventral side he's sort of stoic with his
arms crossed and I would want to look at
more information trying to discern from
a video how long people have known each
other how long they've dated that's
really tough humans are very complex any
behavior that you see at any moment is
really driven by context
number five was interesting because they
were so animated and they seemed to be
in tune with each other though they've
not actually physically touched we can
see there's a lot of closeness one of
the most well supported indicators of
interpersonal closeness is the degree of
non-verbal mimicry between partners I
want to see how close people get to each
other how comfortable they are in each
other's space there's so much mirroring
Behavior they lean towards each other
and they're smiling at the same time
kind of like a movement dance going on
the whole time when you see a lot of
mirroring behaviors you tend to think
okay they've been together for quite a
while it's not a first date yeah
what I'm saying hey we're number three
is a direct contrast there's a lot of
self-soothing displays she was literally
grabbing the table my strategy would be
to really focus on the details what are
they doing with their hands doing with
their gestures maybe they will touch
objects to pacify themselves that was a
very specific behavior that stood out
that she grabbed the table like that to
me that could be a comfortable moment I
see the man here he's doing a lot kind
of with his hands it seems to be a lot
of nervousness when I look at their legs
especially the woman here her legs are
tucked underneath her body and wrapped
together she's not feeling negative so
much because we're seeing some smiles
here but in their lower body I am seeing
some discomfort that this might be the
first date this is a direct contrast
what we're seeing in number two rather
than withdrawing into themselves they're
actually taking up each other's space
very comfortably this maybe isn't a
long-term marriage because there seems
to be a lot of flirting going on which
does tend to die off as their
relationship a ages because there's less
need to show attraction
so we see some flirting going on we're
seeing lots of kind of coy smiles here
on number four the opposite side we see
some finger picking
when people are trait anxious rather
than dispositionally anxious you see
lots of picking of the fingers the
person on the right they still have
their hands low between the legs that's
very much a comforting behavior and even
though the person on the left has both
moved back and forward there was no
reciprocity in other words we usually if
somebody Smiles we smile if somebody
waves we wave reciprocity says I really
enjoy what we're doing here but we're
not seeing that now this could be
because one person has attraction and
one doesn't or maybe one person is
feeling negative towards the other and
the other is trying to get that person
to engage or we can really tell from
this is that there is an asymmetry here
in feelings towards one another if you
may be trying to draw her out and her
mind is is somewhere else
with number one they are interacting but
they have a bit of a bigger distance
they haven't really changed their
positions that much fluidity of action
often speaks of high Comfort if you
notice other couples have moved in and
out of different positions it is very
unusual to remain in the same position
for this long so I'm just wondering if
they're nervous around each other if
they're reluctant to move around too
much
[Music]
okay can you stop number two what we
just saw was I would say very intimate
Behavior she's taking the napkin and
she's giving it to him so that was a
very close proximity while they're
eating she's taking care of him so
definitely a longer relationship than a
first day
number five you just saw a head tilt
that was a headset
not again we call that a clue as you
would say it's getting more and more
interesting at number five because
there's a lot of flirting going on I
would say she's pacifying herself on her
neck there's a little bit of a now you
could say courting maybe going on he's
smiling he's leaning forward that's
interesting to look at
what's interesting about number one is
that we're seeing negative emotion but
we're not seeing any attempt to engage
which would suggest it probably isn't a
first day and it probably is negative
emotion rather than nervousness because
when I contrast this to number three I
see similar signs but in number three I
am seeing a lot of nervous displays
seeing some really heavy breathing here
you can see her chest going up and down
quite a lot she's taking quite deep
breaths the emotions positive but we're
seeing that discomfort at the same time
foreign
number one we see a smile we see some
positive emotion maybe the food is
coming maybe he's apologized to
something one would hope
okay that's definitely a very important
thing that we just saw so now there is a
connection physically she's coming out
of her shelf so to say this is an
intimate Behavior even though it's just
the fingertips you have to remember that
the fingertips are just plush with nerve
endings that are very sensitive this is
a very powerful sign here
[Music]
interesting when the food was brought
over is the first time they're sort of
smiling and and so forth a lot of
comfort displays here she's doing a
little dance while she's eating maybe
they were just hungry and that's where
that negativity is coming from which I
can completely understand you also see
it in number one we're seeing changes in
Behavior I think they were just low on
blood sugar finally a little bit more
animated they're both nodding in
agreement even though they're slightly
reserved maybe because of filming
circumstances they look a little bit
more comfortable now
stop right there oftentimes we can tell
people really are enjoying each other
because they move objects out of the way
so if they have a clearer View
but let's stop here yeah
so she lifts her ankle and it's
ventilating Behavior as well a lot of
people focus on the face not realizing
that the feet are actually more honest
in revealing just how close we are we
don't unveil our feet and we certainly
don't move them this close to the other
person unless we're really comfortable
around them
look how much more animated number four
is now
there's so much mirroring even though
their hands aren't exactly doing the
same thing their faces certainly show
they're really into each other and
number three on the opposite side his
hands have barely left each other this
whole time we're seeing lots of awkward
displays and we're seeing lots of
touching of the menus the nose you might
be itchy but in this case we've seen a
lot of discomfort you see their hand on
her knee that's actually a pacifying
behavior there may be a lot of
nervousness there that we're still
experiencing she's not just touching her
knee she's gripping her neck she's
actually starting to scratch which might
say that the the discomfort level is
actually increasing
number two we're seeing Comfort just
bravely seeing him you know talking with
his mouth full They're laughing while
they're eating and speaking there's less
perception management going on number
two we literally see him picking our
food so that's a very intimate gesture
there you would not do that on a first
date we see a similar Behavior with
number one and they just swapped plates
they picked each other's and swapped not
only did they trade plates but he was
generous and he moved her glass out of
the way I am starting to think that
number one might be a longer term
marriage because they seem so
comfortable in the negativity and what's
interesting here about number three is
we're starting to see them loosen up
we're starting to see a little bit more
Comfort which is what you would expect
as people get to know each other so
we're kind of seeing a progression here
of their comfort levels
and number one even though she's leaning
back her foot is very close to his leg
and that begins to talk to us we saw
some of it in number five they never
really touched but they were willing to
at least venture out that way and so far
we haven't seen it in number three
look at number four yeah because this is
critical it's called foot cradling we do
it with babies we get their feet and we
Comfort them that way this is a high
Comfort display there's a lot of trust
here
foreign
[Music]
look at number two there's a lot of
touching but also longer touches you can
look at the feet and say yeah but they
withdrew their feet well I don't think
that really matters their feet for them
are in a comfortable position look at
the other behaviors that say we're
really comfortable around each other
here's what's interesting for all three
of us is these behaviors at what point
do they become Norm do they become Norm
at three months do they become Norm at
five months or 15 months people who get
along really well within weeks may be
mirroring each other maybe copying each
other how long have they been together
that's really tough it's really tough
and now it's time to guess
oh
I'm heading towards them being married
four years four years one year
I'm Jocelyn and I'm Jake we've been
married for one year I'm not surprised
by this just because they seem so
comfortable and they didn't seem to be
engaging in any perception management
whatsoever for the first few minutes
they just sat there not really moving
not really interacting it's interesting
that now that we're looking directly at
their faces you kind of get a sense of
yeah I can see this as a couple for a
long time
I'm sworn between married four years or
dating five dating five years
I almost put five years for this one
just because they seem so touchy maybe
it wasn't marriage yet maybe this
touching Behavior will slowly start to
fade in the nicest possible way to me
the number doesn't matter the fact is
that you could tell immediately this
coupled really likes each other
of all the couples they're the one that
are closest to a first date
I'm John
well done and with all those touching
behaviors finger touching rubbing that
Sesame we're not really comfortable
I'm gonna go with my gut but I think I'm
rocking Rose
my name is Dora my name is Mercedes yeah
the lack of mimicry was saying to me
that it wasn't a super long term one
thing you can tell how much empathy is
is also displayed when one was reluctant
to to talk or was a little stoic the
other one helped to bring the other one
out that's also a good sign of a good
relationship
I think it's a first date a good one
14 years
I'm kicking myself with this one because
prior to this I said my strategy was
look for the most mimicry they showed
the most mimicry and I just disregarded
my strategy okay we want the PHD back
once again as we look at this couple
yeah we saw the mimicry we saw the
joviality they were having a good time
whether it's a date or an experience in
essence that's really what matters
[Music]